hey I'm ready my name is Bailey and this
is my boy Ethan you enjoying the breeze
boss dog I've lived a lot of lives
there's a lot of different dogs but I
always found my way back to Ethan ow
that isn't getting any easier that is
getting it easier
this is CJ the greatest new addition to
our pack hmm there's nothing in that Cup
I love mornings with our granddaughter
so did I mostly because she gave me
bacon
do you ever taking a bath with the
filthy dog
Oh CJ's mom wants to play too or not
pretty soon CJ had to move away once
don't worry you wind up I wanted to
chase the car but I just didn't have the
energy so much take care of CJ she needs
you like I needed you and then it
happened I was a puppy again and CJ was
my new purpose she was a gigantic baby
now
it it you have to be the authority well
young what is she saying
no idea CJ I have a date tonight again I
could always tell when my girl needed me
when you
as soon as I can I'm getting out of here
then I'm going to New York City wait I
smell my boy it's me really thank you
what makes you think you can just show
up like this we want to see our
granddaughter please you just keep
taking care of CJ big dog you didn't get
up for anything no matter how many lives
it took I would go there for CJ oh hello
where did you come from
like he chose you things don't always
turn out as we plan but sometimes the
surprises are the best part Roger drum
baby don't stop beating
there's lots you don't know about that
I don't have all the answers
but I know we end up where we're meant
to be like a drum my heart never stops
beating for
you
you